ouais il y a fan de ménage qui qui rend
beau l'intérieur des gens quand les gens
sont pas là donc il leur fait des
surprises et il y a la femme de ménage
en milieu hospitalier qui fait que des
chambres pareil toutes foutues pareil
avec pas d'objet pas de pas d'âme
bonsoir
alors avec avec une licence d'histoire
un de athlète et un nombre de diplômes à
faire rougir de honte bon nombre
d'étudiants vous auriez pu trouver un
emploi sans trop de difficultés mais
voilà pour vous le travail en entreprise
est une torture les horaires les
discussions de bureau les ponts entre
collègues tout ça vous fait horreur
alors vous décidez de devenir femme de
ménage oui je suis fan de ménage et fier
de l'aide dites-vous et nous raconterez
votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
vous êtes né à Rennes le 26 novembre
1982 est né d'une famille de trois
enfants terre cheminot mère
aide-soignante dès votre plus jeune âge
votre mère vous transmet le goût de la
propreté et du rangement vous dites j'ai
reproduit ce trait de caractère en le
forçant même un peu trop
ma mère elle est juste ce qu'il faut
elle la maison est toujours nickel moi
ma maison elle est nickel plus
alors au collège vous êtes cancre et
rebelle vous redoublez votre classe de
3e mais un jour un prof décortique vos
notes devant toute la classe et là c'est
la honte vous mettez à travailler et
deux ans plus tard vous avez le bac avec
mention dans une classe où tout le monde
a 16 de moyenne et moi 8
l'humiliation la vie une fois pas deux
donc
assez facilement vous faites une fac
d'histoire dans une université
catholique mais là c'est 3000 euros par
an alors un jour votre mère rentre du
supermarché avec une petite annonce et
quand j'avais une petite languettes là
pour aller faire le ménage c'est une
certaine Madame Seguin et alors elle a
arraché toutes les languettes
effectivement je l'ai eu et du coup le
job ce qui est très drôle dans votre
livre en fait c'est la description des
appartements vous faites le ménage alors
là vous dites c'est un salon style
Conforama 70 avec le grand meuble en
mélamine et marron et la vitrine pleine
de merdouille le salon on met on met des
trucs des coupes de foot des vieilles
photos de mariage des trucs pas
spécialement beau mais qu'on veut pas
jeter en tout cas ça vous intéresse
alors vous travaillerez cinq ans chez
Madame Seguin ensuite vous travaillez
chez les toupets alors là il y a trois
adolescentes vous dites je deviens
ramasseuse de cheveux
repasseuse de linge transparent et alors
il y a une urne à l'entrée une urne
bleue dans laquelle il y a les cendres
du berger allemand j'ai jamais touché
j'ai même pas j'ai même pas ouvert le
truc enfin le palure mais le placard en
lui-même je l'ai laissé
Pascal Sevran là
alors en plus du ménage fait du
baby-sitting et donc à la fin de l'année
scolaire votre mère vous propose un job
d'été lucratif et stable mais moins
drôle aide-soignante dans une clinique
et là vous devenez femme de ménage en
milieu médical et vous dites plus
clairement nettoyeuse de vomi de sang et
de merde
qui qui rend beau l'intérieur des gens
quand les gens sont pas là donc il leur
fait des surprises et il y a la femme de
ménage en milieu hospitalier qui fait
que des chambres pareil toutes foutue
pareil avec pas d'objet pas de Padam
voilà c'est toujours c'est hyper
mécanique c'est comme l'usine quoi c'est
il y a rien de sympa
parce que quand même là c'est en fait je
me suis retrouvé là tous les étés et
c'est ce qui à chaque fois me faisait
reprendre mes études et un jour on vous
dit qu'à Paris une femme de ménage peut
toucher jusqu'à 30 € de l'heure quand le
luxe alors tombé d'abord sur un petit
couple un peu bobo
vous touchez 14 euros de l'heure ce qui
est ce qui est pas mal et vous dites
j'ai les presque envie de leur dire que
c'était trop ben oui parce que enfin
l'habitude c'est 8 euros 9 euros brut et
là elle me dit 14 euros est-ce que ça
vous va j'ai envie de dire oui en même
temps je sais pas c'est trop peut-être
et j'ai rien dit j'ai pris une semaine
plus tard vous trouvez un autre job chez
une actrice
et là vous prenez vraiment goût à votre
vie de bonne quoi vous dites j'adore
quand les gens s'extasient parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais vu leur intérieur aussi
pimpant ça vous plaît
son appart je mets la façon qu'elle
avait d'avoir une maison quoi de mettre
sa vie dans les murs je trouvais ça
génial et en plus c'était hyper propre
donc malheureusement la suite ne sera
pas à l'image de vos débuts parisiens
parce que l'actrice fait un enfant elle
devient tyrannique vous travaillez chez
une certaine Christine qui a cinq chats
et les poils qui vont avec c'est l'odeur
s'épouvantable c'est l'odeur c'est les
poils qui volent ils retombent jamais
enfin je sais pas où ils vont donc pour
les attraper pour les nettoyer on peut
pas parce que on soulève il s'envole il
ressemble si vous ouvrez les fenêtres
elle a peur que les chats se suicident
parce que ces chats étaient un peu bêtes
sauter ça sera pas plus drôle quand vous
travaillerez dans un centre d'action
sociale avec des personnes
âgées souvent handicapées vict d'AVC ou
d'Alzheimer alors une vieille dame on en
arrive une vieille dame qui Alzheimer
qui vous demande toutes les 10 minutes
vous venez
qui est impressionné parce que je viens
de Paris en fait elle habite en proche
banlieue donc que ça étonne quelqu'un
qui habite à Marseille mais là elle a
l'habitude du sac à côté de moi vous
tombez aussi sur une Algérienne
sexagénaire qui vous traite comme une
esclave et qui me met à la laisse parce
que je fais rien quand même
elle veut qu'on balaye un tapis
c'est hyper difficile de balayer un
tapis elle veut qu'on nettoie la
poussière mais juste le boîtier TNT pas
la télé donc c'est pas la façon vous
faites le lit
je mets le drap puis je le replie non
elle fallait le mettre jusqu'en haut et
elle me dit et elle me dit mais vous
avez jamais fait un lit ou quoi depuis
le temps que je suis habitué à faire un
lit au carré en plus aussi sur des
petites arnaques que font les les
patrons et les employeurs soupçonneux
dès qu'il y a un truc qui disparaît vous
regarde ouais mais ils mettent des
petits post-it c'est encore pire
post-it des trucs du genre j'ai perdu
mon petit bracelet avec trois petits
coeurs dessus est-ce que vous l'avez vu
alors il y a ceux qui en profitent aussi
pour [ __ ] le bordel ça ils se disent
finalement il y a la bonne qui va passer
donc j'en ai rien à [ __ ] donc il
laisse la vaisselle dans l'évier tout
voilà c'est terrible ça c'est des ça
c'est en progression en fait au départ
ils veulent montrer quand même les gens
aiment bien montrer qu'ils ont une femme
de ménage mais quand même c'est en
complément j'en fais un petit peu quand
même et plus ça va plus il y en a qui
laisse aller il se révèle comme ils
étaient mais c'était caché un moment et
là ils apparaissent vraiment comme ils
sont il y a ceux qui carottent
c'est-à-dire ça c'est très drôle parce
qu'en fait un quart d'heure de plus ils
vont pas vous le payer mais un quart
d'heure de moi et vous le défalque
c'est souvent alors aujourd'hui vous
êtes toujours étudiante et femme de
ménage alors c'est marrant parce que
vous avez un doctorat en histoire une
licence d'histoire de l'art une licence
de littérature mais vous êtes femme de
ménage vous dites ça me convient alors
j'organise mes horaires comme je veux je
choisis les patrons je veux vous avez
les horaires que vous voulez vous
fréquentez qui vous voulez j'ai un
travail normal dans une dans une boîte
normale
tu fais 8 heures 17 heures tous les
jours du lundi au vendredi
je me rends compte à un moment donné que
ça va durer comme ça 43 ans que je vais
supporter les récits des collègues
pendant 43 ans que je vais jamais
pouvoir cocher le temps qui me reste
parce que j'ai pas assez de calendrier
pour ça je signe pour un CDI un truc
définitif et moins définitif ça me
terrorise j'ai pas envie d'un truc
définitif donc je choisis d'être
professionnellement ce que ce que je
faisais avant comme job d'étudiant
donc voilà vous détestez les rapports
entre entre copines les confidences
devant la machine à café l'esprit
d'équipe ça vous gave donc voilà donc
finalement là vous avez trouvé je suis
toute seule j'ai pas de patron ils sont
pas là ils me confie leur clé je suis
toute seule c'est vraiment
révolutionnaire vous êtes à
contre-courant en tous les cas de tout
ce que tout le monde recherche
exactement mais je suis pas non je pense
pas être la seule il y a beaucoup de
gens que le la routine qu'elle soit au
bureau même si on est super bien payé
même ça peut énerver des gens et on peut
se retrouver un boulot qui est pas
forcément valorisant mais où on se sent
bien vous vous foutez de la valeur
sociale votre boulot en fait je me fous
complètement de la valeur sociale j'ai
de l'ambition j'en ai jamais eu
visiblement j'en aurai jamais et du coup
l'envie d'argent qui va avec je l'ai pas
non plus si j'en ai c'est bien
si j'en ai pas ben je suis avec mais je
me suis pas créé un univers où je suis
obligé de bosser pour réussir pour avoir
de l'argent ce qui compte c'est vrai que
je pense pas à l'avenir du coup mais ce
qui compte dans mon cas à moi étant
donné ma psychologie à moi ce qui compte
c'est que je sois bien là maintenant
aujourd'hui demain Jean-Luc si tous les
Français étaient comme ça la France
serait plus facile à diriger non
la partie genre tiendrait de positif
c'est que ça décrit un métier donc il
n'est jamais question bon vous vous le
prenez bien il vous plaît vous l'avez
choisi faut pas perdre de vue que
beaucoup de gens le subissent que le
SMIC c'est 9 euros brut que 14 euros
c'est beaucoup le côté après c'est un
choix de vie qui est assez exceptionnel
honnêtement c'est du pour nous tous et
du gâchis parce que si vous êtes docteur
si vous êtes licencié vous pouvez donner
aux autres quelque chose qui vous a été
donné à vous-même vous pourriez le
mettre en partage vous le faites pas bon
c'est votre vie vous faites ce que vous
voulez et moi je vais pas vous dire ce
qu'il faut faire de votre vie encore
mais il faut pas non mais juste
simplement ça quoi les pensons à tous
ceux qui le font et qui ne sont pas
docteurs on est d'accord et qui n'ont
pas choisi et qui n'ont pas des horaires
continuent et qui ont des enfants à
charge et et qui sont maltraités ce que
j'ai envie de faire passer quand je fais
la promo de ce livre c'est que moi j'ai
choisi parfois je l'assume parfois je
l'assume pas c'est pas toujours facile
parfois je déprime parfois parfois ça va
mais je pense aussi à toutes celles que
qui font ce boulot par obligation parce
qu'elles n'ont pas de diplôme je pense à
toutes celles qui ont des familles alors
que moi j'ai fait le choix de pas en
avoir je pense à tous ceux parce qu'il y
a des garçons aussi qui sont pas aidés
qui ont pas de famille derrière moi dès
que je suis dans la merde j'ai une aide
donc je suis là je suis je suis la bonne
entre guillemets hyper privilégiée
c'est étonnant non non
c'est vrai qu'on peut considérer qu'il y
a une forme de gâchis du point de vue ce
qu'on peut donner à la société mais en
même temps échapper aux déterminisme
c'est une forme de liberté
c'est glorificateur par rapport à tout
ce qui est tous ceux qui considèrent ces
métiers comme des sous-métiers qui entre
guillemets moi j'en sais j'en sais quand
même un peu parce que ma mère était
femme de ménage quand même donc souvent
être femme de ménage c'est pas très bien
vu par rapport à la société qui qui
aspire à autre chose quoi et donc voilà
c'est vraiment est-ce que vous avez
l'impression de votre mère est une femme
de ménage heureuse
était une forme de ménage heureuse parce
que c'était pour subvenir aux besoins du
foyer donc aux besoins de leurs enfants
donc tant que comme on dit ça a porté un
salaire conséquent pour pouvoir répondre
à notre besoin donc c'est c'était quand
même bien voilà merci c'est fini et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu